- Ready, here we go.
(upbeat music)
My customers aren't interested
in iPhones or iPods.
They're interested in their memories,
where they were able to
dance and sing to a jukebox.
It's all about making people happy.
My name is Perry, and I'm the owner
of Perry's Jukebox and Pinball
Repair Company in Brooklyn.
My business is one of the few businesses
in the country that's capable
of repairing vintage jukeboxes.
These are called vacuum tubes.
In most cases, half of them are good,
half of them are not good.
Ever since I was a child,
I was always interested in motors,
fans and things that moved.
And looking at a jukebox,
the arm, the turntable,
the spinning and the motion
was something that I
was very intrigued by.
(gentle music)
I do around 20 house calls a month
to repair jukeboxes.
I've been asked to go to Ireland,
Tasmania, Thailand and Scotland.
To the correct settings.
Tube is no good.
Most people that call me,
they love their machines.
They have the records in them
from when they were teenagers.
And it brings back memories.
And they think that they're
never gonna work again.
This one's more promising, look at this.
(light music)
Being able to restore the machine,
it's something that
really makes me feel good.
I always leave a house with music playing.